it's amazing dog beautiful what a dog I
don't even like dogs
I like humans I don't give a [ __ ] about
trees [ __ ] nature animals and
all but the people I know that bothers a
lot of people but it bothers me when so
many people don't like people like
everybody always gets so mad at me when
you like you like dogs you're bad guy
you don't care about mother nature
you're bad guy most of you don't like
other people
you're bad guy
I know when that hotline bling
uuugh
sorry guys yeah very good let's do it I
hate being late you don't me to go in
spitting fire hi guys so let's if we're
gonna go you know Facebook live works
it's my legacy you know I never I never
saw this coming
I I love it
I'm I'm taken aback by it every day now
in my life I get an email that's quite
powerful whether it's somebody trying to
survive cancer and watching my show or
somebody starting a career literally
literally no joke no hyperbole walking
out of my building today my doorman
stops me hey mr. B you know it's all
very professional on the Upper East Side
can I show you something
showed me a quote that I said who kind
of went like the the guy or gal that
rose up cooking with her grandmother in
the kitchen is always gonna beat the
person that goes to culinary school you
know it's kind of the essence of doing
it he said that that quote inspired his
friend and changed that person's life
and is now at ironically one of the
great culinary schools and has a
profession it's kind of funny but you
know it's just crazy I mean I I wish it
on all of you I wish it on all of you to
know that even though you're going after
your own self-interests by proxy by
sawdust by process you're bringing so
much good to the world
it's an incredibly intoxicating feeling
and I push against it I don't want to be
Tony Robbins and I don't want to be
Oprah I don't and it's right there for
me I know I've got it but I want to
prove that I'm a real businessman and
all these different things but as I'm
getting old you know it's interesting
literally the thing that happened at 40
it's kind of here's a call back the only
thing that happened is am I being
selfish to prove to everybody that I'm
able to build 100 million dollar
businesses because I want to be a
businessman and then I'm holding off
this inspirational thing that I've got
and should I go all 100% into
inspiration because I'll be successful
and I'll impact more people it's been an
intense feeling it's it's definitely the
thing that I'll spend my 70s 80s 90s and
hundreds
pondering did I play this unbelievably
raw gift properly did I find the right
balance of checking the box of
practicality and not guru for me because
I needed that for me while still helping
enough people along the way it's very
interesting how I feel about this gift
and its gift through communication and
its gift through circumstance and its
gift through being perfectly parented
and its gift through the talents that I
have
but whatever I was given I was given it
the reason I'm reading this audiobook is
because I know I have a responsibility
to read it because Johnny Thompson
reading this is not gonna have the same
impact as the four days I allocated to
this and that will bring value to so
many of you and will inspire so many of
you to do something something great
something good something just a little
bit better than you would have had if we
didn't cross paths actually somewhere
between a podcast yes a meta audio book
yeah it's very unusual and I think it's
gonna be true I really think it's gonna
be really interesting thank you so much
yeah same old same old thank you thank
you guys so much you guys were super I
mean four days that's a lot of time in
my world like the way I roll like you
guys helped me so much you really did
and really day one was especially
challenging and I really appreciate you
guys thank you
did you go to the game last night I did
the knick game how do you feel instead i
furnish an aria nice to meet you hi do
man
Eric Preston Thank You Erik impressively
sweet you guys hey Gary
ya know you want to go around yeah yeah
sure hi Jerry Gary Jamel Jamel nice to
meet you there let's go
hello how are you such a pleasure
are you kidding Kenny nice sorry man
such a familiar face
Gary Gary Harry Harry yeah nice to meet
you yeah I have one already
it shouldn't cook kind of fear with you
are we gonna be okay yep big equipment
thanks bro push it like yours too
hey guys doing all good right good let
me see what can happen right if we
didn't get like the beginnings of it's
something there really we don't want to
know any secrets we just want to know
like I know and we'll just go with the
flow for the first couple hours and then
we'll see check that we could regroup
and be group yeah I like that
I grab job John let's major nice to meet
you guys how are you good you really
well good there's a lot of fun we're not
really like that's literally only a
second time did you buy that on Jack
front yeah
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 178 of the askgaryvee
show it's very exciting day here at
Vayner d-roc you can show it we'll give
him a little we'll give him a little
look of what's going on the big kid
these are the rock are you these are big
cameras the rock I mean you're rolling
with a very small camera is this making
you feel insecure I mean these are
big-ass cameras d-roc you okay yeah
thanks guys I'll see you tomorrow talk
tonight
see you tomorrow man some really glad
you guys are here together I'm really
excited about this like I feel like
there's been a lot of like momentum in
general I'm really excited and really
talked about dailyvee I'm super pumped
about where we are in pre-sales on both
fields I feel like my brand through our
exercises has created a opportunity for
us to like get 4,000 book buys whereas
with jab jab like 1,500 felt a lot to
people you know so my brands in a better
place what I really want to do tonight
and I got to speak to Andy and Alex over
the weekend a little bit so I'm gonna
rely on them to like rekindle stuff
because I'm pretty fried I don't get a
lot of slash later last night I had
dinner with the Warriors team after the
game
the whole team guys the audiobook is
fire guys the audiobook is fire the
audiobook is [ __ ] [ __ ] fire paint
brush it you said it's like go to my
facebook page and tell me what you
thought in school
yeah I kind of did that at the end a
little bit little different
dude I answered like completely
differently like the audiobook has
nothing to do with the book they're like
literally two different things seriously
yeah but I mean I'd like to think off
script I [ __ ] that's a new book yeah
because I don't like reading so I
realized like wait a minute let me just
answer it they're all gonna be the same
or they're most updated thoughts or
they're gonna complement I think the
game I made that change pretty quickly
it's so different right I hate reading
I'm so bad at what you know what's funny
I was definitely better at reading than
I thought
actually you're gonna you're gonna be
blown away but I'll tell what I'm about
to tell you I kind of learned how to
read a little bit I'm not kidding you
know what I did
oh you can just don't hold down the
button you just press it cool all right
all right book squad here's all the
peeps that you interact with your rocks
getting some advice for food Mike's not
letting me there's Andy anyway ladies uh
I think the switch just DoubleTap no
suck it all right guys I need your help
I'm super concerned about local
bookstores because of my tour every
other time has been a pals in Elliot Bay
and changing hands
in the first week I went to the key
bookstores team we need to figure out
Andy who Alex we need to speak to
HarperCollins about the 2550 key
bookstores and then I'm going to need
I'm gonna need you guys to help me
organize around buying books from those
stores whether you do it or you get
people to do it that's what the squads
for I need it so these 30 to 50
bookstores really matter to me in this
comment section can you start talking
about your local bookstore and can you
tomorrow call them and ask them how many
books are in order my prediction is zero
to two that's how local bookstores do it
I need 25 to 50 to 100 for these 50
bookstores so let's start rallying the
community I want you to knock on doors
so for you know like Jack cars that we
could rescue books for the books thro
make them buy the books I really want to
focus on that so I need your help on
that why don't you guys stop
brainstorming in the comments
that's one thing I thought about I
didn't think I saw you between the
channels maíam says within the first 10
minutes Facebook's deciding what's going
on and people know that it's a 30 minute
20 minutes ago yes the Monday morning
video this morning got a hundred eight
thousand organic entrepreneur answer it
is killing on Facebook as a youtube link
yep should we just do more of them
cheers guys to good health to go down
see rocket and you're put the camera
down
super intriguing day for askgaryvee 12
it was very meta
d-roc and I tell Evy thank you keep it
don't out of it a little fried got home
super late got up super early and
tomorrow 5:45 for basketball CNBC
following me around gonna be part of a
new show I get one of the episodes so
d-roc was limited by what he could pick
up today but as you can tell a very big
askgaryvee book day finished off the
recording it seems like there's a lot of
hype for the for the audio book glad
that's done that was smooth I'm very
excited about the meeting we just had a
lot of strategies a lot of thoughts a
lot of contemplating a lot of debating a
lot of putting pieces in place for the
next 36 days before the book comes out
just a really really good day got a lot
of client stuff done good as a dream on
all-star beast just a grinder you know
not the longest day for me you know 6 to
10
six to ten thirty not the longest day
for me but tough didn't get as much
sleep as I wanted looking forward again
except sleep tonight
twenty ten thirty got to be up at 5:30
but angle is be a little bit here catch
up on email bring Brian murdered right
now